this wasn't the triumphant return that
scarf clad Zimbabwean president Emison
Manon Gaga was looking for he'd spent a
week in Europe pleading for foreign
investment while fellow citizens called
for his removal from power still man and
gag was ministers put on an airport
guard of honor he promised the country
prosperity when he won a disputed
election last year but Manon gaga has
presided over an economic meltdown the
country wracked by hyperinflation and
huge shortages of basic commodities here
a woman from the city of Bulawayo takes
Sky News on a tour of the city of Q's
this is another cube the whole of below
era at the moment is the price of fruit
and vegetables has reached stratospheric
levels and the cost of petrol has been
put up a hundred and fifty percent is
there something that you're confident
there manning jaguar can console can fix
No
a soldier soldier convenient they never
renege on what a soldier what what a
soldier knows is to fight it we will be
paid he loots after looting he putted
this boot so that's all again said it
was soldiers and policemen who carried
out a massive crackdown last week
beating hundreds of protesters who
demonstrated against the fuel hike Union
leaders activists and ordinary people
were arrested resulting say critics in a
nationwide culture of fear on his return
to Zimbabwe president Managua urged
people to concentrate on their work but
there's not much work even in Victoria
Falls this town once hosted a booming
tourism industry now few can afford the
fuel they've got petrol at that station
and there are absolutely no queues but
that's because people can't afford to
buy it it's just too expensive no one in
this community is going anywhere
except perhaps the pool hall
[Applause]
every day Zimbabwe is sliding backwards
under a man who promised a new dawn in
the public are losing their patience
John sparks Sky News in northern
Zimbabwe